[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 141 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: So, yeah.
It's good to be
back in the studio.
And this week, we're
going to be talking
with Haben Girma, who is here to
talk to us about accessibility
in tech.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you,
Melanie, for setting this up.
It was a really great interview.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm a little
bit of a fan girl of hers,
because I saw her speak.
And it just blew me away.
And so I was really thrilled
that she not only came out
to speak at "Next,"
that she also
had time to come and join us
while we were recording there.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So that was lovely.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: So before
we get to the interview,
as always, we're going to
start with our cool things
of the week and end with
our question of the week.
And this week's question, Mark
has been able to find for us,
which is going to be, how do I
perform large-scale mutations
in BigQuery--
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: --which
is a good question.
MARK MANDEL: It is
a good question,
because you put a lot
of data in BigQuery.
MELANIE WARRICK: You do.
And in order to make any
type of deleting or anything
that's going to be mutating,
there are some limits.
So it helps give
an understanding
of what those limits are.
But we'll get to that later.
So let's get started with
our cool things of the week.
You want to kick it off?
MARK MANDEL: Do I
want to kick it off?
Why not?
So I think it's worth noting
that Istio, the service
mesh basically for collecting
logs, traces, telemetry,
security, and policy
for distributed
applications basically--
it's the bit that sits between
all the services, the way I
like to think about it.
It went 1.0 recently.
So it's declared
ready for production.
So if you've been
looking at Istio,
but you've been holding
off a little bit
because it hasn't even hit
1.0, it has now hit 1.0.
So you can definitely
check it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: There's a
lot of interest and popularity
around Istio.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know one
of our colleagues, Kelsey
Hightower, talks a lot
about it, which is great.
MARK MANDEL: And we should
probably also mention
that we also have announced the
alpha release of Managed Istio
as well.
So definitely keep an
eye out for that, too.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
We'll probably talk about
that more when beta comes.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
thing we want to talk about
is that Google has
been doing this effort
to make Wi-Fi available
in different regions
around the world.
And so one of those
areas in particular,
they're doing Google
Station, which
is providing high-quality
Wi-Fi hotspots across Nigeria.
The goal is that they want to
roll out 200 locations in five
cities by the end of
2019 and hopefully
bringing this to millions of
people, which is something
that they've been working on for
a while now in other countries,
like India, Indonesia,
Thailand, and Mexico.
We'll include a link, as
always, into the show notes.
And people can check that out
and see what the effort looks
like, what the timeline is, and
some additional insights around
what's being provided.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'm
really excited about this.
A while ago,
episode 17 actually,
we did an interview with
[INAUDIBLE] [? Patel ?]
and [? Dale ?]
[INAUDIBLE] in Africa,
talking about some of the issues
and challenges they face around
infrastructure and how
reliable it is in that region.
So super happy to see this.
Also coupling that with
some of the stuff that's
been going on, like
Google Go Maps Go,
YouTube Go, basically
these applications
that are designed to improve
the experience when there's
an unstable or slower network--
I think these are
really great endeavors.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Just access to information
like this is very important.
I know one of the stats
they mentioned in the blog
is like only 35% of Africans
have access to the web.
So yeah, this is great.
So another cool thing
of the week, I think,
Mark, you wanted to
talk about IntelliJ.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
big fan of IntelliJ.
Been using IntelliJ
for a long time.
This is very specific
for those Java users
that exist out there.
But the Google Cloud tools
for IntelliJ plug-in,
being able to access
services directly
from your IntelliJ IDE.
I thought this was kind of neat.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is neat.
MARK MANDEL: It is neat.
So they have an example
in here of actually
calling the translator API
directly from the IntelliJ IDE.
And there are tools in there
so you can authenticate,
so like you know
who your account is.
Then you can set up
which project you want,
which means if you want to test
out these kind of services,
give them a bit of a demo,
give them a bit of a spin
and see how they work
out, it's very easy
to do from within the IDE.
So yeah, I love IntelliJ.
I don't actually use
it for Java very much.
But for those of you
who do, this probably
would be very useful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Agreed, very much so.
Well Mark, I think it's time
for us to go speak with Haben.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Today,
we are happy to have
with us Haben Girma.
She this morning did a talk--
we're doing this
recording at Next.
And she just talked this morning
on accessibility in tech.
So Haben, thank you so
much for joining us.
HABEN GIRMA: Absolutely.
Thanks for having
me here, Melanie.
And hi, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
Before we get started today
and talk about accessibility
in tech, can you tell us
about you and what do you do?
HABEN GIRMA: My
name is Haben Girma.
And I'm a disability
rights advocate.
I teach individuals
and organizations
how to design with
access in mind.
One of the reasons I do
this is because I myself
have a disability.
I'm deaf-blind.
I have limited
vision and hearing.
There are all these
alternative techniques
for accessing information.
And I've been successful,
because I've found
lots of alternative techniques.
And I've found communities that
value alternative techniques.
For example, during
this podcast,
as Melanie or Mark
speak, their words
are being transcribed and
output into digital braille.
And I'm feeling their
words in digital braille
and then responding by voice.
And this technology
is an example
of an alternative technique.
And people with disabilities
have lots of different tools
and solutions that we use.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
drove you to become
a speaker and a driven
advocate on this topic?
HABEN GIRMA: Disability
has the potential
to be an opportunity
for innovation.
And a lot of people
don't know that.
And I'm really passionate
about teaching organizations,
especially those who focus
on designing technology,
to think of disability as an
opportunity for innovation.
For example, email--
Vint Cerf, one of the
founders of the internet,
helped develop one of the
earliest email protocols.
And this was back
before the internet
existed as we know it today,
back before deaf individuals
had a good tool for
communicating long distance,
because we didn't have good
access to the telephone.
Email was a way to
communicate long distance.
And you could
understand a message
without struggling to hear.
Nowadays, lots of
people use email--
hearing people, deaf people.
And a lot of the challenges
people with disabilities
face from communication
to accessing print, when
you look for a solution, you'll
end up finding a solution that
not only helps people
with disabilities,
but helps the greater population
and becomes the next big thing.
So there are lots
of hidden stories
out there that people
don't know about.
And I'm excited to teach
people these stories
so that more
designers, developers,
people who work in the
field of technology
can start investing
in accessibility.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's so great.
And we actually have a
podcast on Vint Cerf,
so it's funny that
you mention him.
HABEN GIRMA: Excellent.
I didn't know you did.
That's perfect.
I know he's here
at Google, right?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, he is.
MARK MANDEL: So you talk a
lot about tech accessibility.
How do you define that?
HABEN GIRMA: Accessibility
means lots of different things.
The goal is to reach as
many people as possible,
to build one product,
one app, one website
that the maximum number
of people can use.
And there are different
elements to accessibility.
There is visual accessibility,
making sure blind people can
access the service.
The Web Content
Accessibility Guidelines
helps teach how to make
websites accessible.
For apps, there's Android
Accessibility Guidelines.
And for iOS, there's Apple
So if you're making
something, make
sure you follow the
accessibility guidelines
so that it's accessible
to the blind community.
For the deaf community,
the big thing
is captions, making sure
videos have captions
so that deaf individuals
can access the audio content
or for podcasts,
including transcripts
so that people can access
the content of the podcasts.
Those are some examples.
But it's not the limit.
There are lots of
accessibility features
that are waiting to be built.
And if we keep innovating,
we'll come up with new
solutions that will make
even more things accessible.
Self-driving cars-- a lot
of people with disabilities
are excited about
self-driving cars.
We're also worried that we
won't be able to use them.
So we're hopeful that they'll
be designed with access in mind
and future technologies will
so lots of people can use them.
MELANIE WARRICK: When I saw
you speak at Black in AI,
what resonated the most
with me was your point
about how it should be one
technology for everyone,
not multiple.
And that also goes to what
you're saying right now.
Did you want to talk through
a little bit about that point?
HABEN GIRMA: That's
a great point.
Some people, when they
think about accessibility,
they think of a separate special
service, so a separate app
for people with disabilities,
a separate website
for people with disabilities.
Separate is never equal.
You might start out
with good intentions
and intend for the two services
to be equal, but down the line,
the one for people
with disabilities
won't get updated as often.
It won't have all the features.
And it just becomes inferior.
Separate is never equal.
Instead what we want is one
service, one app designed
for everyone to use it.
It becomes easier for everyone.
And some designers immediately
think of design problems,
because they're not used to
thinking about accessibility.
Constraints often
spark innovation
and spark new ways
of doing things.
If you're not sure how
to do something, ask.
Google has an
accessibility team,
so folks here can ask
people about accessibility.
Reach out to the
accessibility team
or reach out to
disability organizations.
There are lots of
organizations in the Bay Area.
There's a San
Francisco lighthouse
for the blind, nationally
National Federation
of the Blind, or for deaf
services, National Association
of the Deaf.
Ask questions.
Reach out to the communities.
Don't make assumptions.
MARK MANDEL: What
challenges do you normally
see from companies
who are potentially
looking to become
more accessible
but haven't quite got there yet?
HABEN GIRMA: A challenge
people often cite is resources.
And people often say that
accessibility is too expensive.
People who say that are
usually jumping to conclusions
and making assumptions
without doing the research.
I will say that it does
take more resources
to try to make something
accessible later
in the stage of development
rather than thinking
about accessibility
from the start.
For example, if somebody
builds a skyscraper and then
after they finish
building it realize, wait,
we forgot elevators,
and then they
have to tear down
part of the building
to add in elevators,
that is more costly
and time consuming
compared to building
an elevator from the start.
Same concept.
It's easier to make
something sensible
if you plan for
accessibility from the start
as you're designing
the product or service.
And if people have more
questions, you can ask.
Lots of organizations and
lots of free resources
online for designing accessibly.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are
some of the subtle biases
that you've seen in the work and
the research that you've done?
HABEN GIRMA: One bias is the
assumption that the disability
market is very small and
it's a charitable thing
to design for accessibility.
It's something to
do for charity.
And people don't realize
that the disability
market is very large.
There are 1.3 billion
people with disabilities
around the world, in the
US 57 million Americans
with disabilities.
That's a large market.
So if you make your
services accessible,
you get to tap into
that large market, which
means more revenue, more
business opportunities.
So it's good business to
invest in accessibility.
Stop thinking about
it as charity.
It's not charity.
It's a great
business opportunity.
MARK MANDEL: Have you
got any great examples
where you've seen
accessibility done really well?
HABEN GIRMA: One classic
example, the city of Berkeley.
Once upon a time,
the city of Berkeley
did not have
accessible sidewalks.
And advocates
complained and advocated
to have full access
to the sidewalks.
And Berkeley put in curb
cuts so that wheelchair users
can go on and off the
sidewalk and travel freely
throughout Berkeley.
Later, parents
with strollers took
advantage of the curb cuts.
And they found that
they could push
their toddlers in strollers
on and off very easily.
Workers pushing things on
wheels, travelers with luggage,
kids with roller blades--
lots of people
ended up benefiting
from these curb cuts.
And this concept of a
disability accessibility feature
benefiting the entire
community is now
called the curb cut effect.
And you see it in lots
of different areas.
Lots of people use elevators.
And it benefits lots of people.
Captions benefit deaf
people, but captions also
benefit hearing people as well.
Sometimes hearing people
are in noisy settings.
And they can't quite hear
what's going on on their video,
so they'll turn on captions
so they can fully understand
what's going on in the video,
or maybe they don't want to--
maybe they don't
want other people
to know they're
watching a video.
And they want to be sneaky.
So they'll turn off the
audio and turn on captions.
A marketing study
by Facebook found
that adding captions to
videos increases view time
on average of about 12%.
So lots of benefits
to including captions.
Curb cut effect.
You see it in lots
of different places.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I love captions.
I use them.
They're very helpful
for me, actually.
HABEN GIRMA: Exactly.
What about you, Mark?
Do you use captions?
MARK MANDEL: I don't.
My wife definitely does, though.
MELANIE WARRICK:
They're very helpful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know you gave
us some great recommendations
on resources.
Are there any
additional resources
that you would recommend
for developers and designers
to improve accessibility design?
HABEN GIRMA: I want
to repeat again
that there are Android
accessibility guidelines
for developers.
Tap into those and
look into that.
And for websites, Web Content
Accessibility Guidelines.
If you're still not sure, there
are lots of online resources.
You can check in with
the San Francisco
Lighthouse for the Blind.
You can check in with
the National Federation
of the Blind.
And there are also
accessibility consultants
you can connect with.
You're welcome to
reach out to me.
Again, my name is Haben Girma.
And my website is
HabenGirma.com.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
Haben, one thing I want to
leave on or at least one
of the last things I want to ask
is, you did this wonderful talk
earlier today.
Can you share with
our audience a few
of the key takeaways that you
shared with the audience here?
HABEN GIRMA: The key takeaway
from my talk this morning
is that all the barriers that
exist are created by people.
They're arbitrary.
They're not necessary at all.
Disability, for example,
is never a barrier.
The barriers created
are created by people.
And one example I gave is
how Harvard once upon a time
used to deny access to women.
Helen Keller, when she was
looking for colleges to attend,
couldn't attend Harvard.
Back then, Harvard
only valued men.
And Harvard wouldn't
admit women.
Over time, Harvard changed.
Society changed.
And now Harvard has
opened its doors
to women, people of color,
and people with disabilities.
So the barriers that
exist are created
by society, not disability.
And as developers,
you have the power
to create tools and
solutions that help people
rather than creating barriers.
MARK MANDEL: So we're at
a technology conference
here at Next.
Is there any particular
technological advances
that you've seen that you
think are going to break down
barriers in the
future for people
with different abilities?
HABEN GIRMA: Self-driving
cars have the potential
to break down
barriers if they're
designed to be accessible.
Will wheelchair users be able
to get in and out of these cars
independently?
Will blind people be able to
drive these cars independently?
How about someone
with arthritis?
So it really depends on
how they're designed.
We're excited.
But we're also worried.
So please don't disappoint us.
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
that's a wonderful point.
Haben, thank you so
much for taking the time
to come and chat with us.
We really appreciate it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
thank you so much.
HABEN GIRMA: You're
very welcome.
Thanks, Melanie and Mark.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And thank you again,
Haben, for coming
on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We really enjoyed
having that interview for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And thanks as well to
her translator for coming
and spending the
time with us as well
and making that
whole thing possible.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Well, Mark, question
of the week?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: How do I
perform large-scale mutations
in BigQuery?
MARK MANDEL: This is an
interesting question.
I don't actually work personally
with BigQuery that often.
So I learned a whole bunch of
stuff looking at this today.
There is a blog post that talks
all about it, strangely enough,
which is why I ended up learning
about it, which is lovely.
So BigQuery, it's
our big data query
system where you can do massive
amounts of data querying
over very large data sets,
terabytes, petabytes of data.
But sometimes you want
to edit that data.
Maybe it went in wrong.
Maybe you want to change it.
Maybe you want to delete some
for archive purposes, all
that kind of good stuff.
So BigQuery does have a
data manipulation language
that you can use, so
like select statements,
merge statements,
update statements,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the limit that
you will hit is
that there are quotas about
the frequency of mutation
that you can make over
the tables that you have.
This is basically because
we do store lots and lots
and lots of data.
And we do very special
things to do it essentially.
So maximum number
of combined update,
delete, and merge statements
per day per table is about 200.
The maximum number
of combined update,
delete, and merge statements
per day per project
is about 10,000.
You can definitely make updates.
And there's no limit of
the amount of size of data
that you manipulate when
you do those manipulations.
So like, a common
scenario might be
where you might want to
update existing data based
on new information coming in
through on a periodic basis.
Just be aware of those
sort of limitations.
So maybe you want
to do that sort
of once a day over the
entire data set if you can
rather than doing it
multiple times per day.
Just keep those
limitations in mind.
But we'll link to
the article, which
has other links to other
articles around like what
the quotas are and like what's
available and what's not.
But yeah, as long as you
keep in mind those quotas,
you should be good to go.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Everything that's going
on with data in general,
this is a key thing to
be able to work through.
Check out that link.
All right, Mark, where
are you going to be?
MARK MANDEL: I am going to
be at PAX Dev and PAX West.
So PAX Dev will be
starting August 28th.
So I should really
book my flights.
I will be talking about
[? Agonez ?] at PAX Dev
and then hanging out at PAX
West with all my gaming friends
and cosplaying friends and
all the other good stuff.
Melanie, where are
you going to be?
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK:
So as we speak, I'm
actually in Vegas
at all the security
conferences that are going on--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's right.
Yeah, yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: --with DEF
CON and BSides and Black
Hat and all that.
This is my first time.
And this is interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
I'm excited for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, me too.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: So it's good.
Outside of that, I think that's
most of the conferences for me
right now, which is great.
MARK MANDEL: That is great.
Oh, I should
mention, I will also
be at Tokyo next in September.
That will be the thing
I'm doing afterwards.
So that will be awesome as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I
actually, since you're
going to bring up
September, will
be at Deep Learning Indaba
in South Africa in September.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
Fantastic.
Well, Melanie, thank
you again for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.